I'm actually a senior fellow at Harvard
in the program on the legal profession I
write about this a lot I was very
involved in sort of changing the way
inside lawyers do their job I believe
that there is a major change because of
the economic conditions where
corporations are putting tighter budgets
on law firms which is why law firms are
being forced to either layoff partners
senior associates and are not hiring as
many young people I think for people
going to law school and I think this is
a good thing to be perfectly honest they
need to think of other kinds of careers
and there are many opportunities in the
public sector and the nonprofit sector
that they can take advantage of so I do
think we're going to see a decline in
legal business because corporations are
just going to be tighter on their
budgets and that's going to last for a
long time then that will be mean less
business for law firms I also think that
I've written about this that we're going
to move away from the hourly billing
rate towards something called a fixed
fee we're basically you pay a price for
a legal service even if it's a complex
one we don't build fee-for-service on an
hourly basis it's a problem in the
medical profession it's why health care
costs are running away the problem the
legal profession that's why health care
costs a legal costs are running away so
we've got to solve a problem in both the
law and medicine
fee arrangements what are called
alternative fee arrangements are
definitely happening in in a number of
firms and a number of major corporations
are pushing very hard to change the
economic relationship when I came to GE
we changed the paradigm for inside
lawyers we got great lawyers to come
inside and that meant that there could
be more cooperation between the inside
lawyers who are the equal of the outside
lawyers on matters but there was always
a dispute about money what the fixed fee
will do hopefully will create a
partnership on the money as well as on
the matters and that will be beneficial
both for the companies for the law firms
and I think for the public interest